a few months ago I did parkour up in
Scotland and I made the mistake just
absent-mindedly saying uh that I want to
try uh I want to try tightrope now
this is Chris
hello the the bolzini family uh circus
yard circus yeah that's where you are
and tightrope is my thing so you've
definitely come to the right place if
you want to try tightrope I know he's
tightrope the right word because I've
heard high wire and you can call it what
you like it's a tensioned uh steel wire
rope which is high
so the reason why we call it high wire
as opposed to tight wire or dance wire
they sometimes call a lower wire is
because of the height obviously so it's
a slightly different mental and physical
training so so how are you with Heights
Tom I I'm fine with height falling
falling not so much
um it's it's not the fun it's not even
the funny it's more of the landing um
this would be dangerous yeah you're fine
but first the first 20 meters will be
great the next exactly well the plan is
not to drop you on the ground that's
that's my job
um so so don't worry you're in safe
hands um but there is definitely a lot
about the the mental process of
preparing yourself
um so that's what I want to do with you
is to get you feeling really calm and
really grounded having a healthy respect
for Heights and an awareness that you
don't want your body to fall off and hit
the ground for me that's sane that's
that's not being wimpy or foolish that
is actually really sensible and really
sane and and that's why the technique
the training and and the safety harness
in this case are really essential to you
know we're not we're not as crazy as we
look
I don't know what to expect here I don't
know the height of what we're oh that is
that that's the height basically I saw
um Penn and Teller once oh yeah I know
we're doing a something stuck in my head
yeah was the phrase the trick is the
same whether the Rope is one foot off
the ground yeah or gonna get about 30
feet off the ground yeah it's actually a
little bit less so it's already less
than okay then you're worried about it's
eight meters eight meters
um it's serious injury territory if you
come off though isn't it that's uh well
it won't be for you no time it would be
for me because I work with that safety
harness but um yeah it's really not
about the f word and in fact your
training starts there don't mention the
f word okay um it's it's really not
about that what we always have to do is
step onto the wire and be present on the
wire with the confidence that we are in
control and we choose when we're gonna
get off the wire so really visualizing
that really establishing that in your
mind's eye
that's where it starts is believing that
you can do it normally at this point I
would have kind of some sarcastic or
self-defense but no I'm going to buy
into this because I'm going to be up
there soon cool I'm absolutely I'm not
going to mention the f word I'm gonna
walk across there great great great well
that's that's the place to start from
and yeah I believe you can do it so you
know that's at least one of us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Cube balance like that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so we're not going to start you up there
we're going to start you on something
much safer and lower just down here uh
so if you wanna if you want to come this
way I'm just going to put the final
tension on to make sure that it's about
right and just do that on this little
device that should be good like that
so here's your balance pole that's uh
that's good that's got let's go
it's wide there's a lot of balance
available here is what I'm doing it's
very long it is actually a shorter one
come and have a feel of the pole on the
ground okay uh and then I shall talk
through some of the technique before we
get you onto the wire okay it's it's
heavier than I thought it was going to
be yeah that's what people always say um
this one is about eight to ten kilos all
right so how you hold it if you bring
your hands a little bit wider bring the
flat of your palm so your fingers are
not even gripped around it that's it
that's better and then bring it up so
that the middle of it is yeah around
your belly good now pull your elbows in
towards your body and dropping your
shoulders down the back okay now that is
much better a little bit wider the hands
a little bit wider Okay cool so what I
want is that your fingers don't have to
hold on it feels more like I've got a
thing just resting in each Palm yeah to
start with yes if you need to wrap the
fingers around you can put it down if
you need to rest your arms yeah I think
I'll save the uh save the muscles and
again just Pat the arms out massage out
because you'll be getting a lot of
tension it's heavier than I thought it
was going to be yeah yeah yeah yeah so
let me show you I'll show you first of
all without the pole okay
um and if you want to just watch and you
can almost imagine yourself if you like
you can imagine yourself being me
um and just be aware that when the feet
uh get on the the correct foot position
is for the big toe to be over the wire
and then through the middle of the heel
at the back
and when you stand up onto the wire
you'll have the pole but I'm just going
to balance with my hands and then my
teacher in Cuba used to say like this it
goes on
Talon Paso so that's touch toe forward
slide
Hill
step that's right toe slide heel step
yeah so what we're doing with the eyes
we're looking at a fixed point
and the best fixed point to look at is
the point at the end of The Wire
because
that's where we want to arrive let's
start with the feet yep and I can help
you with the with the pull
all right so so if you hold that and if
you remember yep yeah the center Palm
open Palm on the belly yeah yeah I'm
going to support this so we don't have
to worry too much about balancing okay
because we want to get those feet good
if you need to fall off yeah I'll just
show you this if you stand there for a
second there are two ways to leave the
wire if you really have to leave The
Wire yeah one way which is not advisable
it's like that yes I have made that
mistake once in my life on a slack line
in a park and it hurt yes yep you only
need to do that one yep to realize that
that's the way not to do it so being
really aware that if you do need to
leave the wire then to go one side or
the other magic when you're ready
come up with the other foot
stand up tall and straight bring the
pole up to your belly good keep looking
at the end of The Wire both feet on the
wire fantastic
okay okay
wow so that that moves uh
that moves a lot okay it's really lovely
the wire will wobble so if you can use
your breath to calm your body
that's a super cool super cool toe on
The Wire toe on The Wire when you're
ready
great and other foot on The Wire
good uh okay Bree pull the pole to your
belly yeah pull up a bit elbows into the
body cool and when you're ready step
forwards
and try to sleep okay you got it you got
it stand up straight stand strong okay
okay okay
if you need to lean onto the pole yep so
this is this is the the next
step okay we're gonna try a bit of this
now so when you get up onto the wire
with the pole and if you feel like you
need to
um fall off
no no but then you're getting more
comfortable with where your feet are on
the wire remember toe yep slide
pull the pole into the belly good toe
okay just keep breathing keep breathing
you got it cool toe good so make sure
your foot is really on the way really
touch gently test that the wire is there
before you commit to the footstep yeah
okay where the vibration is coming from
um it's just from your body so relax
your body use the out breath to relax
okay okay check where's the wire in
front the wires moving too much
I can't take away the wiring yeah
because the answer is it's doing that
the way that you're lightly touching
with the front foot as you slide so
that's damping it's like dampening a
guitar string you know if you touch onto
it lightly you'll stop it vibrating wow
really stay focused right till the very
last okay cool all right welcome to the
assist on that
I guess we just do that a lot of times
now
[Music]
okay lost it lost it lost it lost it
halfway
[Music]
I need to put the pole down I need to
physically put the pole down yeah oh
[Music]
I'm keeping my feet in a claw position
it's painful I need to let that relax
yeah
okay cool I can nearly hit you with a
pole ladder sorry I've I've had poles in
the face before now I'm uh comes with
the territory well done man that was
really good I touched down a few times
over there but the problems in the soles
that hurts now yeah they're just not
used to having a thin metal wire
cutting into them yeah I can only only
imagine painful and it's putting all the
pressure on the same bit every step
Okay no Okay ah it's that pressure over
and over and over and over and over I
might propose
that we have a look at getting you high
um and see how we go from there you're
at a place where you're making you're
picking up the pole on your own you're
balancing it all the way across to the
middle and then yeah it's you're being
restricted by the pain in your feet it's
a process yeah surrender to the places
okay
see what it's like from the top then
yeah yeah great that's really cool and
yeah step into that space and you'll see
that it's there's not a lot to stand on
there's not but it's if this is wobbling
I'd have a problem if I didn't have the
wire on I'd have a problem yeah
I'm okay with this this is fine cool
cool that on the other hand
that's a lot longer than I thought it
was good before you look out there too
much take a look around and get a view
of Somerset that most people don't ever
get to see yeah I'm gonna just go out a
little bit more here uh-huh yeah the
height is not bothering me cool that's
fine this wire bounces up and down more
than that one does yeah it's a little
bit longer wire so there is more
elasticity in it this is good if I can
do if I can cross that wire
I think I can cross this wire
right now
from my own peace of mind when I'm up
here
could I try descending on this cable I'm
happy with that all right so all I need
to do is yeah the problem is just
putting my faith in this yeah sitting
down oh that's the all right you you got
me
and then just trust us there's some
elasticity here he's got me he said he
does indeed yeah you got me thank you
very much
this is uh
this is undignified I think it looks
better with flailing Tom it does it
really does move the feet and arms yeah
just just sitting there like a sack of
wet potatoes didn't help thank you very
much Josh
all right okay super ah
no no no no no no no no
oh foot pain foot pain
work on those footsteps nope okay okay
stay present stay present Stand Tall
straight easy two more steps clear steps
okay easy
super
that's it so really working with your
relationship to your body your feet in
this moment
and keeping that pulse strong
but Loose
we're feeling the pole
and sliding those feet keeping forwards
keeping moving forwards good you can
step on the cover letter no problem
great because I was going to cool cool
come on
look at this come on keep going forward
come on stay strong in the belly come on
keep stabbing a step yeah really I want
to hear it breathing keep breathing all
the way through you've got six steps to
go keep going
slowly slowly at the end wait all the
way until you're right there
yes
all right you did it cool
have yourself a little break I have no
idea why that suddenly worked I have
absolutely no idea that hurt like hell
at the end and I have no idea why my
brain suddenly went you've got this you
have got that first two three steps
something went click and I guarantee you
if I do that again right now I'll be off
straight away don't say that I don't
think that don't even think that
something about that was just I've got
this this is the pattern it's locked in
I'm going to make a rubber band race car
this is a crate from kiwico who make
Hands-On fun educational projects for
kids of all ages so if you've got kids
and you'd like to keep them occupied and
interested without just shoving an iPad
in front of them this may be for you
they've sent me this which is a tinker
crate for ages 9 and up and as there are
actually kids around here I'm gonna make
it myself
every month kiwico will send out a new
crate with Hands-On projects about
science engineering art geography or
cooking or whatever your kids particular
interests are oh that's clever okay
there are nine different types of crate
like the koala crate for preschoolers or
the doodle crate for kids 9 to 13 with
an interest in art and design or the
maker crate for 14 and up yours may not
look as even that's okay
all right all the crates have been put
together by expert designers and
engineers and tested by kids and all the
instructions tools and materials you
need are included they really did think
of everything here that's really nice
you can go to kiwico.com Tom Scott or
click the link in the description to get
50 off your first month of any crate
I would have genuinely enjoyed that as a
kid
genuinely enjoyed that now
[Music]
so how are you feeling after yesterday
do you feel like you're you're ready for
today my my thighs hurt weirdly out of
all the bits my feet were fine this
morning like like great
I tried to his count them they're
they're doing okay yeah thighs hurt arms
hurt a bit but I think I'll be okay okay
I just
I just want to make sure I get over this
one a few times before
getting up there first one of day two
yeah like I woke up
I woke up with completely unjustified
confidence I woke up going I'm fine it's
gonna be great
um
I don't even say you earned your
confidence yeah I would say you worked
harder than I've seen anyone who does
this work yesterday so yeah breathing
breathing
yeah we're not there yet
come on Tom come on get your eye in you
had this yesterday cool let it touch
it's great keep the body straight as you
do say let the arms bend down but keep
the body straight
easy easy
great that was the best one I've seen
you do
I would normally be trying to almost
distract myself try and let my
unconscious subconscious whatever it is
do the balancing for me yeah but I have
to keep my head in the game focusing on
what I'm doing as soon as I start
talking as soon as I start
focusing on what's going on outside
well I won't use the word but yeah I see
it as a forced meditation yeah
how much of that foot pain yesterday was
me being scared I don't know oh 100 I
I'm not saying 100 that was
that I think a better question is how
much are we capable of if we let go of
all the fear
let's do it again let's do it again
enforced meditation is absolutely the
right term anytime I feel my brain going
nope not thinking about that right every
time I have to bring it back refocus on
that it's definitely true all you've got
to do is what you do here
how's that great do I have a rest give
yourself a you know a bit of a sit down
rest your feet we'll get the pole up and
we'll get the um the harness ready for
you all right amazing well done let's do
it thank you thank you
I can tell you that that first step is
the most difficult one that you'll ever
make in your right walking career
um and that's not saying to rush it to
quickly get down but to commit when you
take up the pole
make a decision that you want to go
forward yeah take up the pole and then
embark on a Crossing yeah all I need to
do is get that pole from there to there
exactly all right let's do it okay
there is a lot more wind up here today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
trick
whether the tightrope
is half a meter off the ground
or eight meters off the ground
it's exactly the same thing
[Music]
it's exactly the same thing pull up
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Stay Strong Lift the chest up stay nice
and tall
golden thread from the center of the
head
I got you
I got you don't you worry stay holding
the pole Josh can you grab the pole
foreign
okay coming in the last bit
thanks Josh
let's do it again
let's do it again
let's do it again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
stand up tall stand up straight
strong and Tall Tom keep breathing
slowly walking forwards keep with your
balance keep breathing check those
footsteps one by one keep breathing with
your breath I want to hear you breathe
[Applause]
keep going slowly take your time
take it one step at a time you're all
right straighten up
okay easy step by step take your time
two feet on the wire please
work it fight for it good
keep breathing keep present
keep going little by little
slow it down take your time
you have all the time in the world all
the space in the world this is your
space
okay control of the pole
fight for it Tom easy slow down
breathing
breathing all the way five steps slow it
down
and yes
yes
thank you Chris all right thank you Tom
well done man super cool super cool it's
the same trick
I can happily just stand on this wire
with hands on here
but you're right
I would have touched the ground there
I've considered that a failure there's
one point it felt like the pole was way
off down to this I might throw up in a
minute have you ever seen anyone vomit
from eight meter why take your time take
your time to breathe take your time to
feel grounded to arrive into that place
of safety
foreign
[Music]
oh that was sketchy at the end doesn't
matter how much you know that's there
you still feel like you're gonna fall
it's incredible don't use the f word
hahaha